中島聡さん、他2名の新作が届きました
フォロー中のクリエイターの新作です！
中島聡
Elon Muskはなぜ「ガスタービン会社」を買ったのか？
「エーアイ導入率88パーセント」はなぜ現場を速くしないのか？
中島聡
テスラとSpaceXが合併するなら、テスラの値段は「$2T」で決まっているのか？
梶谷健人
【だいじなご報告】 エーアイをフル活用して2つのサービスを1人で開発しました ＆ βテストに招待します！
中島聡
ロボタクシーの時代に、なぜUberが有利なのか？
頭の中の独り言は、いつまで「誰にも触れない場所」でいられるのか？
中島聡
xAIの「混乱」は敗北なのか、それとも優先順位の切り替えなのか？
エーアイの利用量は、まだS字カーブの入口なのか？
中島聡
SpaceXは八四半期でロケット会社から「計算能力の会社」に変わるのか？
シニアエンジニア一人とエーアイエージェントは、五人チームを超えるのか？
中島聡
インターネットは、もう人間のものではなくなるのか？
デジタル庁
⾏政⼿続等調査データ（約75,000件）をMCPで⾃然⾔語分析可能に
中島聡
AlphaGoの「Move 37」は、ひらめきではなくチップの速さが生んだのか？
半導体の露光装置に、粒子加速器が使われる日は来るのか？
中島聡
エーアイは半導体エンジニアの人手不足を埋められるのか？
その他の新作
きょうのあなたにおすすめの記事が届いています！
BigShip |  ひとり法人2期目
診断士2次試験まで75日 | 情報収集＆徐々に始動
ペン太郎@大企業幹部の日常と投資
【就職・転職】おすすめできる、できない業界業種
総合コンサル@1億円貯める
総合コンサルの金融資産｜社会人8年目｜2026年7月
がむ27卒＠28卒向けやさしい就活
2002年、世界最大のIT企業が、BIG4の一角だった「PwCコンサルティング部門」を丸ごと買収したという事実を知っていますか。
IBMコンサルティングの知られざる出自｜コンサル就活ガイド
早川雅映（はやかわまさてる）
パラレルワールド？
虚数？
あの世？
——早川雅映の視点とエーアイ麦子の応答
中堅コンサル（コンサル系情報発信/仕事術/サバイブ術/キャリア形成etc.）
エーアイ時代のコンサルジュニアの生き残り方/エーアイとの向き合い方
jin
PIPになった部下と半年向き合って、私がさいごに出した結論
Pro Bro - タツ
転職は何回までOK？
- ジョブホッパーになる境目
ふっき
外資IT物語 | 四半期末の絶望とカタルシス
もっと見る
ヘルプ /
利用規約
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。